hey guys welcome to part two of this
special series of awesome bill where we
look at the Mad Max fury road review
props and costumes so I did initially
shoot a bunch of footage from behind the
scenes kind of stuff that I intended to
release either as a part of this series
like an awesome bill type show or maybe
just even know behind the scenes or a
special feature for one of the DVDs
let's take a look hey everybody
alright so today we're gonna be building
and mortem Joe's mask from Mad Max fury
road last Halloween I picked this up
thinking that I was gonna build a
steampunk gas mask Oh Sam a couple of
canisters sticking out of it had some
goggles and stuff and wasn't long after
that I picked it up to sit on my shelf
that they released the trailer for bad
max fury road and then instantly I knew
that this was going to be a morose mask
however it's been a year and has this
been sitting on my shelf and finally
this project has come up and given me
the excuse to actually go through with
it
so that's we're gonna do today we're
gonna turn this into this it's a good
basic shell but it's not very movie
accurate obviously so we have to be
making a lot of alterations cutting
quite a bit of it out andrey sculpting
and probably standing some pieces down
of course painting and everything I
would I'll be sculpting with is plastic
whoa you guys have seen me use this all
the time
plastic ball is a two-part epoxy putty
that it's good for plumbing and stuff
like that this particular one is made by
JBL actually I'm not even sure if they
make it anymore last time I was at the
hardware store there was a bunch of my
clearance so I just bought them all up
they were all marked down
my guess is is that neither they make a
similar product now or they discontinue
this one but I know that you can find
other plumbers putty like epoxy putty
that work pretty well
there's now like this one is because it
lasts a while if you get it wet you can
smooth it relate Eisley that here is
really nice the plastic and it takes a
little time to set some of them set
within like five minutes
some of them set within like three or
four minutes so you have a very limited
amount of work time but this particular
one Pat lasts a while so you can kind of
alter it and make changes and stuff like
that it has its drying even even if you
use a plastic sculptor or something like
that
also just a piece of flexible tubing
this one's a little small for for the
one that's in the movie it's pretty
close though
the reason I like this one is one it was
very cheap is about 75 cents to as it's
really flexible if you buy like a vacuum
hose or I think they have like hose for
dishwashers and stuff like that or and
you go on the plumbing area there's a
couple of different types of this ribbed
hose a lot of them are very rigid though
and you don't have a great deal of
flexibility I got this one actually at
American science and surplus or is it
come it's been full of this flexible
hose and you could go to their website
American science and surplus that
governments where you find various hoses
I don't know if you find this particular
one because it's kind of surplus stuff
they get a bunch of crap in and as they
sell it you know they might sell out and
not never curate again so so that being
said we're just gonna dive right in and
start sculpting I'll probably be using
some other various pieces of PVC and
stuff like that
for the go inside here not sure what I'm
gonna use yet although the detailing
stuff like that we're actually gonna
just sculpt directly onto the mask
everything is pretty much going to be
covered up I'm going to sand all the the
chin area and the one in the movie
actually is more vivid it's gonna kind
of like that divot splits so I have to
every sculpt a little bit there and then
the nose will probably have to be kind
of ground down or sanded and then it's
got sort of a rounder into it it doesn't
have this no and the teeth are gonna
have to be rescaled it heavily somewhat
because and the teeth on the mask in the
movie they're sort of divided it means
it's there's like up to one big tooth on
either side this one's actually got like
a tooth in the middle and two fairly big
ones on the side but yeah so a lot of
work needs to be done to this thing but
in the end I think it's a pretty good
it's a good solid base and you don't
have to try it out I am completely
sculpted from scratch you've got you
know what fits and it already kind of
has the look you know I mean so alright
get to it so here I've already sanded
down the chin in the nose and edit some
epoxy putty to the insider to nose to
kind of close it off and here I'm using
a sharpie to block off all the areas
where I'm going to add more of the epoxy
putty or the plastic well I had to do it
in sections because it does cure
relatively quickly it just gives me a
better idea to know exactly how much I'm
going to need and I can kind of see it
ahead of time how it all is going to
look there play out
so I took a piece of PVC that I'm gonna
use for the respirator to make those
circles in the mouth I'm going to round
it out clean up all the edges so that
the piece of PVC fits really smooth all
right and so I'm finally applying the
plastic walls and you can see me wet my
hands and that's so that I can get a
really clean smooth finish without
having to go in and sand it afterwards
you can't it's it's and a bow drill bowl
it's carvable but what's really nice
about the plastic weld is you can wet
your fingers and go over it with your
fainting out with your hands and smooth
it out really nice and then you can get
a really nice clean finish without
having to go back and sanded so now
before it's completely cured it's
getting hard but it's still hit a little
bit play in it so I'm using that
sculpting tool to add some of the little
crevices and deep cuts and texture to
the teeth and the chin the different
elements that aren't going to be metal
or that need to be clean like teen
things like the teeth and the bits of
sinew and stuff like that in the upper
jaw lower jaw
and see I'm actually like doing little
increments at a time I'm breaking out
small pieces mixing it and applying it
as I go because I don't want to add too
much I want to make sure that I was
using enough at the same time being very
conservative I guess you could say with
the amount that I was applying so that I
wouldn't have to try and take any off or
do any sand or anything like that after
the fact I kind of wanted it all to just
cure so that I can immediately go right
into painting
all right so for the the connectors here
for the respirator I was I got these PVC
pieces but then I also have these little
cannons that I was going to use for the
truck model that I wound up not using
and the pattern on it is actually great
what you take the actual cannon off it
has that texture and design that's very
similar to the one on the respirator so
I'm gonna attach those and then a piece
of PVC and connect the hose that
actually it's kind of a neat little
finder it's a neat little kind of a
happy accident is about Ross would say
so yeah it is one of those things so you
never throw anything away if you keep
little bits of crap eventually you'll
use it on something so lesson of the day
kids
okay so I gave the entire mask a coat of
black semi-gloss using the Krylon color
fusion I wanted to give it a semi-gloss
so that when I added the metallic or the
gray metallic paint it really made those
metallic elements seem to pop and really
like they had a really nice finish on
here I'm plying using something Brown
I'm just kind of dabbling it in to all
of the crevices and stuff so that when I
go over the next pass I'm gonna use a
red to highlight all of the raised areas
most the time I just use spray paint
sometimes I'll use some acrylics but a
lot of the time it's just spray paint
I'll just spray a little bit onto a
piece of cardboard over some plastic and
use a cheap brush and to do my dry
brushing and stuff like that
here I'm doing the same thing I'm just
doing a couple of coats over the teeth
and having it black it really leaves
those little cuts in his hooves that I
made in the teeth and in the jaw and
stuff like that pretty pop
all the screws and rivets are sculpted
you don't have to sculpt them you could
use like fake beads or actual screw
heads and stuff like that pushed into
the epoxy but it was easier for me to
just sculpt them as opposed to using the
actual elements because it was just
faster
alright so the paint job is done a
pretty quick jab it's not perfect but I
kind of get the idea
yeah looks enough like it I think to
where it's not perfect but it's mediocre
all right so that's it for this week
bought between in next week because
we're going to continue the series part
three is going to focus mostly on the
furiosa costume that or curiosa costume
actually that we built for tamara and a
lot of it's going to be focusing on the
arm and the mechanical arm and stuff
like that so once again thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time